ce qui se passe aujourd'hui en France
les Français ils en ont marre ils disent
à chaque fois on se recueille on est
triste on se dit on espère que ça
reprendra pas et ça reprend parce qu'il
n'y a pas je vous le dis il n'y a pas
d'exemplarité il n'y a pas de de voilà
de de peine exemplaire
parce que l'histoire elle va durer des
semaines et des semaines et ben après
les gens vont oublier et puis après on
verra tiens trop filer ah bah tiens elle
a été placée ou truc ou bien l'après je
vous le dis aujourd'hui on ne veut plus
de ça je pense que ce qui est
démagogique c'est plus que vous
dites-vous et aujourd'hui ce que vous
dites pour moi je vous dis c'est plus
audible pour les pour les Français on en
peut plus on en peut plus d'entendre ça
je voudrais vous répondre c'est une
France dépassée sans esprit polémique
vous l'aurez bien compris le procès
permet de toucher à la vérité un procès
ça permet de comprendre ce qui s'est
passé pour les parents mais les parents
ont besoin de savoir regardez le procès
des attentats du Bataclan ça a duré 9
mois on a besoin de comprendre
vous jugez en 24 heures vous ne
comprenez pas ce qui s'est passé mais
écoutez l'instruction s'est fait pour ça
je suis pas d'accord la justice elle est
faite pour la manifestation de la vérité
ou alors on supprime l'institution
judiciaire du tout je suis pas d'accord
avec vous je suis d'accord il peut avoir
un procès pour la peine voilà immédiat
et ensuite après oui donner des éléments
aux parents et aux familles pour dire ce
qui s'est passé mais je vais vous dire
aujourd'hui je pense que franchement
énormément de Français sont d'accord
avec moi on n'en peut plus de cette de
ce laxisme juridique et de ce qui se
passe actuellement ça va encore durer
des mois et des mois elle va avoir un
avocat elle va pouvoir se défendre ils
vont plaider les responsabilités ça
marche ou pas et ça va recommencer et il
y aura encore un autre problème
aujourd'hui pourquoi on fait pourquoi on
parle de ça encore aujourd'hui c'est
parce qu'on a envie que ça n'arrive plus
on en peut plus de ça entièrement
d'accord bah oui mais c'est
insupportable
et aujourd'hui bien sûr qu'il faut
prendre des mesures et aujourd'hui je
trouve que les lois ne sont pas adaptées
à la société actuelle je sais pas ce que
vous en pensez en raison serrer là elle
est en prison
surtout s'il ne faut pas juger les fous
pourquoi il faudrait les protéger
pourquoi cette dame c'est ça l'envoyer
en prison c'est quoi l'intérêt
en prison il risque de ressortir les uns
et les autres à part quelques quelques
cas où on a la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité perpétuelle fournirait on
avait bénéficié si je puis me permettre
mais ils sont extrêmement rares ces cas
en France donc moi je voudrais vous dire
une chose
je vais peut-être un peu m'avancer
mais j'ai lu ici ou là des choses qui
m'ont interpellé
je rappelle que je me suis beaucoup
occupé des sectes professionnelle
qu'est-ce que je constate dans cette
affaire que ça me rappelle ça me
rappelle l'affaire des enfants des
urines vous connaissez les enfants qui
sont appelés au Maroc ou en Algérie des
souris c'est-à-dire qui sont considérés
comme ayant des pouvoirs généralement ce
sont des blonds yeux bleus qui ont des
caractéristiques morphologiques et ces
enfants souris il y a plein d'affaires
actuellement qui sont jugés en Algérie
c'est un vrai drame en Algérie ils sont
kidnappés ils sont sacrifiés on boit
leur sang il y a des rites sataniques et
sur cette pauvre fillette il y avait le
chiffre 1 sur la plante de son pied
gauche et le chiffre 0 et elle a dit
semble-t-il dans sa garde à vue qu'elle
avait bu son sang c'est exactement le
rite satanique des jurys qu'on trouve en
Afrique du Nord c'est pour ça que moi
j'ai besoin de savoir qu'est-ce qui a
inspiré cette femme voyez bien sûr non
mais ça on a on va voir jugé comme ça en
24 heures il faut comprendre mais encore
une fois je parle avec beaucoup de
prudence je dis ça m'a fait penser à
cela